[Music]
we often sit around and dream up
interesting jobs or TV shows and we
think we have a pretty cool job and then
all of a sudden Seaton goes hey thinking
about having Jack Maxwell on at the
Super Bowl he does a booze traveler on
Travel Channel and I thought that's
something we would have thought of
Paulie you go around the world and you
have drinks with people we'd done that
part of it yes we've been doing this for
years and somehow Jack Maxwell ripped us
off to come up with booze traveler
Mondays at 10:00 Eastern 9:00 Central
and Travel Channel good to have you jack
my apologies for stealing your idea
actually it's not even my idea someone
else pitched it I just auditioned I mean
how do you audition to be the booze
traveler drink all of that and stand
stand straight up no it's it was strange
they wouldn't say what the show was
because they didn't want anyone to rip
off the idea because that happens right
so they just started asking questions
and said would you eat this would you
drink that they said would you would you
eat Rocky Mountain Oysters which we all
know both testicles and you don't say no
ever at an audition sure whatever you
say there's ah ha but would you drink
them in vodka they said okay but what
would you call that I say it sounds like
a highball they wanted to go with that
so they said that's the conceit of the
show that's the idea that guy goes
around the world having cocktail should
have fun
so we explore different cultures around
the world through the lens of a cocktail
glass basically you know what is the
strangest concoction you've consumed
whoa well there's strange and then
there's hard to get down I'll throw them
out there and everybody will probably
have a different one as it goes number
one spit beer the women of the village
get together in Peru in the Amazon we
found a tribe they threw up this Papa
they spit it into a ball its ferments
over a week and then you drink it
then this frog in a blender they peel a
frog throw it in the blender with no
skin tree root moonshine and then spin
it up in this blood going all over the
thing then you have to drink it right
away
that's 2/3 cow blood with the Maasai
warriors in Tanzania they shoot a cow in
the neck with a blunted arrow blood
gushes out into a gourd and they mix it
with honey wine you drink it warm should
I stop or keep calm that's good how
you're in an India hangover cure cow
urine I'd rather have the hangover but
that's if they drink wait do they
actually say now did you drink it having
a hangover so did it cure a hangover I
didn't have much of a hangover that day
it just happened to wit the way the show
broke they said well the next segment is
this and okay
I really didn't have much of a hangover
but it's impolite to go to a culture and
say I'm not gonna do that if they bring
me in and teach me how to do this and
that and share their food and their
friends and their family then say here's
a crazy drink you have to do it it's
part of the culture right but when you
go how much of this is part of just
experience in a culture and
understanding how much these drinks mean
to that culture and the etiquette of of
going into these these tribes in areas
around the country that's exactly what
it's about that's right because it's
it's about drinks but not drinking I
don't get yes hammered all over the
world right but you'd be surprised how
much more ceremonial drinking is around
the world
it means spiritual things to them they
pour it onto the ground they they pray
beforehand they give it up to the gods
so alcohol really ties in to who they
are and they they always invoke their
ancestors much more ceremonial around
the world than here I think where was
and when was beer invented oh well you
know there's there's a lot of everyone
wants to say they invented it first of
all like the pisco sour Peru has fights
with other countries around no we
invited so they made the first Saturday
in February is national pisco sour they
improve to say no we invented it and
other countries say no we did so beer
wine they think the first alcohol on
earth
was some kind of honey Mead there was
fermented honey maybe water mixed in
analog and someone drank it so who
that's good how can we sell it looking
part of that so it I don't know that
people know exactly where beer was
invented for the first time although a
lot of countries would claim it I think
did you hear a story that we of course
broke here on the Dan Patrick show Tom
Brady was a world-class beer chugger in
college
I heard the young Tom Brady world-class
beer sugar I can't believe that because
he's so disciplined now right you
imagine having Brady on your show booze
traveler little cameo are you teasing us
I'm from Boston Boston although he loves
the Pats come on our show will chug some
beers the best place that you've in the
United States personal favorites in the
United States place to drink yeah aside
from Massachusetts yeah cuz it's always
nice to go home right yeah
there are so many great bars like you're
gonna take me to one bar right now in
the United States that I have to go to
okay the first thing I'd say is what do
you like do you like beaches do you like
biker bars do you like no this is the
one experience that I can't pass up no
matter what I like to drink or where I
like to go is in the United States yeah
where you just say you gotta experience
this Wow probably I was in Miami
recently went out we went out on a yacht
they this is the experience they put
everything out on the yacht food drinks
and it's just for you and a friend or a
date or whatever go out on the yacht you
sail around the harbor but that's not a
bar it is though that's what they do
that's there's just you and me look I
don't wanna go one place I think it's
really cool it doesn't have to be
romantic the Boston of course because
I'd go back there California up and down
the coast
there's some great haunted bars this
great should we travel with you for show
yes can I come with you on a show is
what I want to do no but this
you're you're here yes we would like to
travel would you like to go because
booze traveler is mostly international
but I'm doing a second show now called
booze travel the best bars in America so
we're just starting when I find one I'll
let you know we'll go there how about do
one in the Northeast okay maybe with New
York City yeah we'll come down and we'll
pound promise yeah so we're gonna do
that soon Yeah right
Yeah right there and you gotta bring Tom
Brady right yeah I'll bring him yes
absolutely
and body shots are they do you find that
is religious experience as well I don't
know because they're more respectful to
alcohol and yeah yeah no but we did have
an awkward moment between the actually
watch it done if you if you have a
chance I love them I don't know how they
do it every year somebody is in a row no
did Belichick sell his soul to the devil
how does he do it he probably got draft
picks if he did on top of that right
trade it down how does he do it I don't
I love them we're not talking sports on
this show the show tonight Israel Israel
Israel little Wailing Wall
yeah it was whaling one of course you
don't drink there Dead Sea and drank
date liquor we also went to the West
Bank which is strange because you can't
go there if you're an Israeli so our
Palestinian fixers have to take us to
West Bank and we race we street race in
Palestine in the West Bank with two
sisters called the speed sisters and
they drive crazy around the neighborhood
taking turns dodging people it's really
nutso that's tonight I'm going to Israel
with my family next next Christmas
around Christmas New Year's time so you
gonna have to let me know where I'm
supposed to go I don't know if you're
gonna be able to do body shots out of
people's belly buttons prissy you don't
drink in America let alone Israel that
wasn't the main reason we're going to
Israel you know my daughter is having on
compartments for a few months after that
we throw be nice being Jewish to see our
heritage and but maybe I will have a
drink or two
yeah body Israel is a huge bachelor
party destination really hot this time
of year where do we need to go in
Houston see new uh do you have a list
here well I would say the Pat's bar
below diablo Loco the crazy devil oh and
there's some that's the only Patriots
bar in Houston and there's no Falcons
bar huh yeah see don't they have like a
makeshift on here I don't know if they
probably put one up now because all the
fans coming about I don't think so bun B
is a good one oh yeah bun P is so great
part of the underground underground
Kingz is around cool rap icon and we
went to eighth wonder brewery together
which they also serve it's not just a
brewery and they named the beer after
him but eighth one that was great check
that out that's it that's a great place
the show is booze traveler it's on it's
not the Travel Channel
it's Travel Channel it's Travel Channel
okay 10:00 Eastern 9:00 central Jack
Maxwell will be coming to a country near
you thank you for coming in and thanks
for meeting we're gonna we're gonna come
in please join me the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]